Eleanor Williams the girl who lied and
kicked up a storm in the seaside town of
Barrow in finesse in May 2020 she posted
shocking photos of her injuries on
Facebook and claimed she was being
physically and sexually abused by evil
and clever men an Asian gang who
trafficked her to sex parties
[Applause]
but then after a police investigation
and trial a jury at Preston Crown Court
found that everything was a lie even the
injuries were self-inflicted
but miss Williams's fake story echoed
the stories of real victims some who
were inclined to believe her if only
because when they reported their abuse
they felt the police investigated them
more than the men women such as Laura
who even when we spoke to her last year
said she was troubled by the case it's
kind of a similar story to me like being
exploited by lots of different men and
being taken to different areas and then
she's been arrested that really really
scared me because I was like I'm talking
to the police about a similar crime like
what if I get arrested
it's why despite the conviction on
compelling evidence many alleged victims
like Susie from the northeast of England
still think Miss Williams must have
suffered from some form of abuse and
feel the case has caused damage
I think
it makes us all look like liars and it
makes everyone
well me especially and other girls but
like we just wouldn't want to come
forward indeed when Eleanor Williams was
sentenced to eight and a half years in
prison for perverting the course of
Justice the judge expressed this concern
we are aware that sex trafficking of
young females does occur
there is a risk that genuine victims
will as a result of this defendant's
actions feel deterred from reporting it
but some women fear the case may affect
police attitudes a young woman from
Barrow told us when she reported sexual
assault the case was closed not long
after Miss Williams's Facebook post went
up because she thinks the man she was
accusing although not named as a victim
in the Williams case was connected to
her claims I give my bed in the whole
bed and it was a double bed I give them
up pajamas
and then after the ad the evidence the
Admiral statement we had an email saying
that was no further action was there any
indication that the police weren't
taking you seriously because they
thought you were
another her yeah yeah that's how you
feel yeah
but Cumbria police told us the decision
was reached after a four-month
investigation including one arrest which
did not provide evidence to go to court
they added the case was investigated by
officers who were not involved in the
Eleanor Williams investigation to
suggest that Eleanor Williams lying had
any influence on this case being no
further action or resulted in the police
not believing victims is completely
baseless and false
and this prosecutor involved in the
Williams case says her crimes only came
to light because police were
investigating so diligently this case if
anything would demonstrate a true and
genuine victims just how seriously these
kind of cases are investigated before
the pervert in the course of justice and
charges were preferred against Miss
Williams there was a lot of safeguarding
around her and lots of Investigation
into all the allegations she made but
the hard truth is that only a fraction
of women who allege being raped actually
get a prosecution and it's likely that a
woman found guilty of lying will only
make matters worse
Jason Farrell Sky News